I'm Frankie Vijaya from Indonesia
cinemas agriculture and food I also and
the in the Chamber of Commerce heading
the agriculture site and also the pizza
a grow which is stand for partnership
for Indonesia sustainable agriculture
which I think all these three that what
we are doing for the sustainable
agriculture I think is very exciting and
and can be very fruitful for all of us
for food security and sustainability and
at the same time also good for the
economic itself and for good for the
smallholder especially so these are the
things that we are developing and I hope
that all what you call it if somebody
would like to know more or can
contribute to this initiative I really
hope that we can connect each others
through the world academic forum thank
you